- Alright.
I like to find the most
heartwarming stories
from the internet and share them here.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
If you've ever lived
in an apartment with thin walls, I have.
And you know that your business
is everyone else's as well.
Very thin walls.
We can hear you arguing.
So what do you do if
your newborn cries a lot?
Well, you should take a page
from this New York couple
who posted a peace offering
on their front door.
It reads, we have a newborn.
He is loud, we are sorry.
He's cute as (beep), but very noisy.
Bear with us.
Thanks to your patience.
Take a nip or two at your leisure.
And below the sign is a bucket of alcohol.
(audience laughing)
These are my kind of people.
Let's get these very
considerate parents in here.
Meet Kristen and Todd watching
on NBC4 in New York everybody.
(audience clapping)
Oh my god, the little one.
Well, Kristen and Todd first,
congrats on the new baby. Oh.
So where did you--
- Thank you.
- Where did y'all get this idea
to give your neighbors some
alcohol so they'll be happy?
- He's really, really loud
and alcohol can solve many problems
when things get stressful.
So figured it'd be a nice peace offering.
- Yeah. Todd was out doing
his laundry in the elevator
and could hear how loud Quint was.
- Yeah, I could hear him
screaming from our elevator
while I was doing laundry and I ran inside
and was like I'm going to make a sign
and we're going to a liquor store.
And we have like a little bucket that
like a little bathrobe for him came in
that I just filled with nips
and attached it to our front door.
And the rest is history.
I think our neighbors enjoyed it.
Social media seemed to
enjoy it, so we're happy.
- [Kelly] Cause it's thoughtful.
- And he seems to be happy too.
- I wish I was that
kind of happy right now.
That's a slumber I haven't
experienced in a minute.
So Todd, is it possible
Quint takes after you
because like aren't you a musician?
Are you kinda loud?
- Yeah, I'm loud.
I'm a special education
music teacher in Brooklyn.
I like to hear myself talk.
I've been playing in punk rock
bands for like two decades.
I currently play in a band
called United Blood NYC.
You can find us on Instagram.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And if you like what you
see, follow Milk Stain NYC.
That's our family.
- I love that.
- [Kristen] Thanks Kelly.
(audience clapping)
- Well, congratulations on your family
and also congratulations
on being respectable kind
neighbors and thoughtful.
Thank you so much, Kristen.
Thank you Todd.
Thank you Quint.
I'm liking your post right now.
And that's not all y'all.
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor considerate
people like yourselves.
So they're gonna be helping
you by writing you a check
for a thousand dollars so you
can replenish that alcohol.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- Thank you guys so much.
And thank you to all our guests this hour.
Keanu Reeves, Ian McShane,
Lance Reddick, Shamier Anderson,
Hiroyuki Sanada, and also Chad
Stahelski and Emily Kaufman.
Y'all have a great day
and if it's not we'll try and change it.